in this video i'm going to talk to you
about why starting a software company as
an information and service marketer
e-course guru etc is a terrible [ __ ]
idea if you don't know who i am my name
is alex remozy on acquisition.com it's a
portfolio of companies that now does
over 100 million a year and i have
nothing to sell you in this video i'm
just here to trigger a handful of you
and hopefully give a warning a strong
warning to those of you who want to do
it now the question you might ask is why
would somebody want to start a software
company when they have an e-learning
core service etc well i'll tell you why
it's because they think that one it's
going to make their service company
stickier because they're like ah
software's sticky no no no no software
is not sticky really good software is
sticky your software will not be sticky
and will just cost you a lot of money
but let's just say that's number one
reason that they want to do it the
second reason that they want to do it
and this is the even shittier one is
that they think it's going to give them
a really good multiple upon exit all
right when they sell their company in
the future now let's start breaking down
why this is such [ __ ] terrible advice
and idea in general now if you even look
at the entire info guru etc space that's
out there how many of them have had big
successful software exits
i'll wait
right there's only one guy who may have
an exit and that's alex becker and it's
because he made the flip from being a
guru and selling courses and things like
that to a true software entrepreneur the
problem is 99 of people want to continue
to run their info business and then
drive it to a software company in which
case they do both kind of shitty and
never actually get a the exit be sticky
software and so they end up just having
a kind of shitty mix in between because
there's another person who's trying to
solve the exact same problem and doing
it better than them because all they
focus on is the software right and if
you're getting into the software game
and you think that like oh i'm just
gonna market it and it's just like a
course and then people are just gonna
have to stick with it because i
introduced them to it it's not true
that's not gonna happen you have to be
really good at software and really know
a lot about the business and not only
that software is one of the hardest
businesses to get into for a variety of
reasons number one it costs money to
develop stuff now you're like oh i'm
gonna have an offshore team has its own
risks right and making sure that the
product is actually what you want but
let's just assume that you you know have
figured all that out right you have the
cost of development that's number one
number two the people you're competing
against now are software people and they
are much smarter in general than i would
say the guru world is at large and
that's because there's real money to be
made there but it is a high-stakes game
and if you look at like the vc world
venture capital angel things like that
the reason that their portfolio theory
works is because they make a hundred
bets knowing that two of them are going
to carry the entire portfolio the thing
is is that when you are one of those
hundred the likely that yours succeeds
is very very low and so what you do is
you take your eye off the main game and
then play the one in 50 game likelihood
of succeeding and then you end up
basically destroying both and wondering
and then what happens is sunk cost
fallacy kicks in you're like well i put
all this money in i put all this time
and i set it publicly my ego is now
attached to it etc then you want it to
be like i'm a smart cookie i'm going to
move above the space but you're not
and they're not going to give you the
multiple that you think you they are and
here's why it's not that tech gets great
multiples so hear me out on this the
future value of a company is based on a
discount applied to future sales between
now and the day that the company dies
and so the number of sales that they
think they could potentially generate in
terms of how big the market could
potentially be and the likelihood that
those sales occur okay now if you have a
software that churns people out and mind
you in software world they measure churn
annually not monthly annually and so if
you have less than or above 10 annual
churn on your software you're [ __ ]
you're just a service business right and
so you probably don't have those types
of turn metrics which is probably why
your software sucks and so unless you're
a hardcore true god you know balls to
bones software entrepreneur and you know
everything about that world and you're
willing to risk it to go all in on this
which is why a lot of these guys use
funding up front because sometimes in a
lot of software companies need to have
funding in order to get the initial
stuff off the ground so they can get
market share and then they can start
upselling people later right it's a much
more competitive space i just see so
many people trying to do this and it's
just it's just not what you think it is
right like it's just based on how likely
the sales you have in your business are
to occur in the future okay so insurance
for example gets good multiples but all
and it's because the likely that people
continue to stay and use the same
insurance insurer is high it's not
because tech is magic or insurance is
magic or whatever is magic if you have a
service business that never loses anyone
and each in each client continues to
spend more with you over time you're
gonna have a very valuable business
period you'll get a much higher multiple
right because all they care about is how
likely what's my risk and then what's my
upside right like that's what they're
looking at and then how likely is is it
that i that either of those scenarios
occur and that's called risk adjusted
return and so if you have something that
people never stop paying for and they
continue to buy more of it and you have
more people that you could sell to in
the future that's a very attractive
business software is just a vehicle to
get there people think that they're just
going to slap you know some [ __ ]
software that they have paid you know
some dude in bangladesh 50 grand to put
together and think that they're all of a
second to take their 2 million profit
business and get a 20 x top line
multiple on it it's horse [ __ ] you're
not gonna get that like the people who
are going to give you the money are
smarter than you they're smarter than me
they're smarter than all of us and the
reason they have 100 million dollars to
give you is because they're not [ __ ]
dumb think about that they got the money
because they earned it they're not
stupid right they get it by making the
right bets and i mean i i heard this one
the other day so what i'm going to do is
i'm gonna get people to subscribe to my
software for my for my mastermind and
then i'm gonna classify it as a level of
the software they're not [ __ ] idiots
they know it's not it's not software
that people are using because they're
gonna look at time on screen they're
gonna look at daily users and look at
how much each of the each of the
elements according to where they want to
drive value for whatever they're buying
it for they might be buying it to plug
it in they might buy it because they
think they can expand it they might buy
it for a variety of reasons right but
the real real is that most of them never
get bought and it's because they're
actually [ __ ] software made by
people who don't understand software and
think that they're going to decrease
their turn or somehow make their
business more valuable and neither of
those things are true and what ends up
really happening the vast majority of
the time is that the product you make is
not the best one on the market you start
pitching it to your customers and they
start complaining and they will tell you
that it's not the best one and then you
feel like you're losing integrity
because there is a better person on the
marketplace that is better for the
solving the specific problem and if you
do have a real competitor in that place
who really does play the software game
they'll just look at your [ __ ] and copy
it in two seconds because software is a
competitive space and then they'll have
all your stuff plus theirs and a better
user experience than you have and
probably for less and so all of a sudden
you're hawking something that just has a
worse value proposition but you feel
invested because you spend all this time
and effort and you feel like your
identity is tied to it and then all of a
sudden your bravado kicks in because you
don't want to be seen as a failure
publicly and so
recipe for failure instead alex's
recommendation is stick to your game if
you have a service company just make
your service stickier make it more
likely that people will stay with you
that will increase the value of your
company buy other companies that have
similar names similar that are have
similar characteristics and enroll them
in if you so choose or find affiliate
partners or get more referrals or run
more paid ads or do more outbounds you
can get more customers figure out ways
you can serve more customers you can
expand your tam you can just make the
company you have more valuable rather
than trying to think that you're going
to trick some potential acquirer like
they're not dumb i'm just going to say
this again they're not stupid think
about the people that you know who can
stroke 100 million dollar 500 million
dollar check they didn't get there by
being morons so why would you expect
them to to buy your [ __ ] software
that you tacked onto your service
business to automate one thing be like
well i'm tech enabled cert no you're not
you're either service or you're tech
period and if you if you are a tech
company then you will know you're a true
tech company because you wouldn't be
watching this video because you'll be
like oh no i obviously i love competing
against these other guys who try and
make [ __ ] software right and if
you're not a tech guy and that's not
your world then play the game you're
best at where you have a competitive
advantage
right this is what happens and i'm gonna
i'll wrap it up in a second people hear
that you can get 10 times top line 20
times top 50 times top line right for
software but that's not the vast
majority of software's in general that
gets sold not only that most offers
don't get sold at all most software's
fail like i've mentioned earlier in the
vc angel example but of the software's
itself most of them don't sell for much
they sell for parts and then of the very
very very small examples of the ones
that hit those crazy multiples it's
because they have tremendous growth
they're not losing users they're getting
people off of word of mouth the people
are they hit product market fit which by
the way is by use tell if the way that
you get people in your software is that
you sell them your service and then you
tell them to use the software it's not a
good software people need to buy it so
that we know that the problem that we
are solving is valuable to them they
need to use it regularly on their own
and they need to tell other people
specifically about the software until
those three things occur the software is
not valuable think about it if you're
just blowing people through your
software software vehicle and people
cancel when they cancel your service
it's just service and you just added
some weird tech thing that's completely
nonsensical to the service offering that
you have rather than just making a
probably smarter affiliate relationship
with someone and getting probably more
profit from that relationship because
you don't have the cost of everything
running the business and if you send a
serious amount of traffic to somebody
you can probably negotiate 20 30
sometimes 40 50 affiliate relations
depending on you know the type of
software etc and so i say this to say as
a big warning to the vast majority of
the people that are out there and this
this tends to happen right around that
like i want to say like one to three ish
million dollar mark is when people think
they're gonna get cute they're gonna get
fancy they're gonna be like i'm smarter
than the space i'm smarter than these
people i'm really trying to get away
from from all this guru shed all this
all this servicing these customers who
don't understand my value it's not that
good that's why they're not saying like
that's that's the real like you look
yourself in the mirror and be like
they're not staying because we are not
fulfilling our promises and then that is
where you actually start to make real
money and build something that's
sellable and has value and i promise you
that when you actually solve the problem
you're not going to want to sell because
you're going to love the business
because customers come highly
recommended you have a great reputation
people get more than they pay for they
they bring their friends you sleep well
at night because your employees enjoy
servicing the customers that you have
segmented as your ideal avatar and those
people are connected and send more
people your way and because people
aren't turning out the back door left
and right you know that next month your
month is going to be bigger than it was
this month even if you do nothing that's
how a good business runs and it takes
time to get there and people get
impatient and so they try and think that
there's a shortcut and there isn't there
just isn't you just have to be better
and better takes work
work takes time that's all i got mother
nation love you guys keep being awesome
i'll see you guys next one